What do a mouthful of live moths, an army of
cats, and a crazy Bette Midler fan have in
common? "Hocus Pocus" might not be the
cult classic it is today without them.
Although today he's one of the top actors in
Hollywood, Leonardo DiCaprio was young and
unproven in the early 1990s. His first official
movie credit came via "Critters 3" in 1991,
and he starred alongside Robert
De Niro in his next feature film,
1993's "This Boy's Life." According to him,
the actor then had to make a difficult choice
as to which film he wanted to appear in next.
In a 2014 interview with Variety, DiCaprio
recalled being offered "more money than
[he] ever dreamed of" to star in "Hocus
Pocus." Instead of accepting, however,
he opted to hold out for a role
in "What's Eating Gilbert Grape,"
a movie he hadn't even auditioned
for yet. The Oscar winner admitted,
"I don't know where the hell I got the nerve.
But if there's one thing I'm very proud of,
it's being a young man who
was sticking to my guns."
DiCaprio had auditioned for the part of Max
Dennison, which eventually went to "Dallas" actor
Omri Katz. While Katz gave a fine performance
as the film's leading man, you have to wonder
just how different "Hocus Pocus" would have looked
with a future A-lister like DiCaprio in the role.
"I'm the king of the world. Wooo!"
Eagle-eyed fans on Reddit have noticed that
in the Halloween party scene of "Hocus Pocus,"
there's someone in the background wearing
what appears to be an outfit from 1982's
"Tron." As it turns out, that man's costume
is more authentic than you might realize.
When speaking to Glamour, Mary Vogt, the
costume designer for "Hocus Pocus," admitted
that she spent almost all the wardrobe
budget creating the iconic looks of the
Sanderson sisters and the zombified Billy
Butcherson. This made for a particularly
sticky situation when the script called
for the Dennisons to attend a crowded
Halloween party toward the end of the film
and Vogt "had completely run out of money."
So what did she do? Well, she took advantage of
the fact that she was working on a Disney movie,
raiding the Walt Disney costume
department and selecting outfits
from a slew of old Disney movies. The
Emmy-nominated costume designer recalled,
"I think that if you paid $5,000,
you could have whatever you want.
So I went through there and took
everything that looked like a costume."
No wonder so many of those Halloween
outfits look so impressively genuine.
There's a scene in "Hocus Pocus"
when the zombified Billy Butcherson
finally catches up to Max and the
gang — but then, in a plot twist,
sides with the children against his ex-lovers.
You might recall that during this scene,
Billy cuts open his sewn-up mouth and several
moths fly out. Being that this was the '90s,
the stunt was performed without the assistance
of CGI. But you have to imagine that Doug Jones,
the veteran physical maestro who brought
Butcherson to life, wishes there was.
In an interview with Bloody Disgusting, Tony
Gardner, the makeup FX master behind "Hocus
Pocus," shared some photos and facts about
the film's behind the scenes happenings,
including that Jones actually had real
moths in his mouth during that scene.
Gardner explained that his team attached
a latex pocket between the actor's upper
and lower dentures, completely blocking
his throat ... and then came the moths.
"An animal wrangler would place
several moths in the pocket with
tweezers, under the supervision of a
representative from the Humane Society."
Jones himself vividly recalls the experience,
telling E! News that he could feel the moths
fluttering around inside his mouth. Making
matters worse, a light burst on set while
filming the first attempt, so Jones had
to redo the entire process. In retrospect,
Jones probably deserves an Academy Award
for enduring the moths not once, but twice.
There's a joke Jimmy Kimmel said
about a strict policy that he has:
"I will not and do not publicize unsubstantiated
rumors about anyone ...
unless they're very funny."
This must have been the mindset that
Doug Jones had when he publicly shared
a pretty wild rumor about his legendary
costar, Bette Midler, telling E! News,
"I heard rumor that she had written
into her contract that there had to
be an isolated shot of her feet
walking somewhere in the film,"
While anonymous rumors are obviously not a solid
source of information, there are actually two
very suspicious shots of Midler's feet during
the Halloween party scene that certainly lend
fuel to the fire — one when she enters the room,
and another when she's walking across the stage.
While it could simply be a
coincidence, Jones isn't buying.
"Why would they even bother to put that
clip in there? I think it was contractual."
Sometimes it takes a good movie several years to
become fully appreciated. There's a plethora of
solid films that bombed at the box office because
they were arguably ahead of their time, including
cult classics like "Labyrinth," "Heathers" and,
of course, "Blade Runner," which famously only
took home $26 million on a reported budget of
$28 million, but is now recognized as one of
the best sci-fi flicks of all time. "Hocus Pocus"
achieved a similar type of delayed appreciation.
When speaking to Forbes in 2020,
director Kenny Ortega opened up
about how poorly the film did at the
box office, only grossing $39.5 million.
"Honestly, at that point, I
thought it was all over for me."
However, history had other plans for the
director and his little film that could. "Hocus
Pocus" slowly but surely landed with its intended
audience, evolving into something truly special.
Looking back, Ortega is grateful for
the example the movie set in his life.
"What I've learned is don't give up. I believed
in 'Hocus Pocus' ... and even though it wasn't
found by audiences immediately, the
generations have believed in it."
They say don't meet your heroes, but Kathy
Najimy would beg to differ. Before she
landed the role of Mary Sanderson, Najimy was
already familiar with her on-screen sister,
Bette Midler. However, the
two had never actually met.
During a 2019 interview with Metro Weekly, the
"Veep" actress explained that she had been a,
quote, "crazy sycophant
fan" of Midler's growing up,
so getting cast to play her sister in
"Hocus Pocus" was a dream come true.
"When I was growing up the idol
of my life was Bette Midler and
I used to break into backstages
of where she was performing."
In addition to sneaking backstage at her shows,
Najimy also admitted to one audacious
occasion in which she posed as a worker
for a singing telegram company and sang
Midler a song while wearing a bunny suit.
When asked whether she ever told Midler that
she was the bunny suit singer from her past,
Najimy says she did come clean, but it probably
took Midler a while to come to terms with it.
"I think it was just a very
slow sort of like, 'Oh God,
I'm making a movie with a crazy person,'
into very good castmates and friends."
While "Hocus Pocus" is obviously a fictional
tale, the roots of witchcraft in early America
are anything but. The Salem Witch Trials of
1692 are some of the most fascinating events
in American history, albeit a grisly example of
how intense paranoia can lead to mass chaos. Over
the course of seven months, over 200 people in
the Puritan town of Salem, Massachusetts were
accused of witchcraft, ultimately resulting
in twenty innocent people being murdered.
One such person accused of witchcraft was named
Esther Dutch Elwell, who, as fate would have it,
is actually the tenth-great grandma to actress
Sarah Jessica Parker, the ditzy witch Sarah
Sanderson in "Hocus Pocus." The "Sex and the City"
star learned of this stunning relation in 2010,
while appearing on the American version of the
British TV series "Who Do You Think You Are?"
Fortunately for Elwell, the trial court
for witchcraft was dissolved a few weeks
before her hearing, so she was freed
and able to live a full life. Still,
the fact that one of her distant
relatives would eventually play a
witch from roughly that same time period
is a rather fortuitous coincidence.
Although "Hocus Pocus" is clearly a
movie intended for the Halloween season,
it actually hit theaters in July.
This means that filming for the
movie actually took place around Christmas
time, which made things a little tricky.
While some of "Hocus Pocus" was filmed
at studios in California, some of the
production did actually take place in Salem,
Massachusetts for authenticity. Unfortunately,
when the crew traveled to Salem, people were
starting to put up their Christmas ornaments.
While holiday cheer is great, this
was for the wrong holiday. Thus,
action had to be taken, so the filmmakers got out
their checkbooks and began approaching the locals.
Actor Tobias Jelinek told E! News,
"They were having to pay them out, block by block,
to take down all their decorations so
we could get all the Halloween stuff."
One of the scenes shot in LA
is the one in which Max, Dani,
and Allison celebrate having just bested
the witches by dancing around in a park
outside the school. Although there's nothing
particularly special about this short scene,
internet sleuths have discovered an
unexpected cameo in the background.
As it turns out, this scene was filmed
at the old Warner Bros. ranch in Burbank,
the exact same location where the iconic intro
for "Friends" was shot. You can clearly see
the fountain that Joey, Rachel and the gang play
around in behind Dani as she prances in the park.
As entertaining as "Hocus Pocus" is, the journey
of the screenplay behind the movie is arguably
even more interesting. At the 2018 Midsummer
Scream, some of the cast and crew members from
Disney's fan-favorite Halloween flick reunited for
the 25th anniversary of the film's release. One of
the members on the panel was David Kirschner,
the man credited with creating the story.
Kirschner explained that it started
as a bedtime story he would tell to
his daughters. He eventually wrote it
as a short story and it got published
in Muppet Magazine. Then, in 1986, the
story was transformed into a screenplay,
where it would sit in limbo for eight years. When
Kirschner finally did sell the story to Disney,
he reportedly brought in loads of Halloween
decorations, including a giant bag chock full
of candy corn so that the executives "smelled
their childhood" while he gave his pitch.
Thackery Binx, a young boy from the late 1600s,
was cursed by Winifred Sanderson to live forever
in the form of a black cat. Binx is one of
the high points of the movie, periodically
cracking jokes at Max's expense while watching
over Dani as though she was his own sister.
"Take good care of Dani, Max. You'll
never know how precious she is."
According to Humane Hollywood, there were
several different cats that played Binx
throughout the movie, and the handlers chose
which cat would appear in which scene based
on their skills and personalities. American
Humane was present throughout production,
ensuring that no animals were
harmed during filming. It's truly
impressive what the crew was able
to accomplish with animal actors.